RONALD SMITH: So last time, we
derived a formula for the
equilibrium temperature
of a planet.
And I'm not going to go
back over that much.
The first column of information
here is a
continuation of that.
But the way we did it was to
consider the Earth as a kind
of reservoir of heat that
can store heat.
It can receive heat from
the Sun, and it can
radiate heat to space.
And then we tried to consider
how that system might come
into a steady-state balance.
So we were thinking of this very
much like the water tank.
If I plotted temperature
versus time--
oh, I have to excuse myself for
the slow writing today.
I think I've dislocated my
shoulder, so I'm going to be
doing it two-handed.
The lesson of the
day is wear your
helmet when you're biking.
I did, so my head is OK,
but my shoulder's not.
So if I started the Earth at
some temperature but I was--
let's say I started it at zero
temperature, zero Kelvin.
This is unrealistic.
It probably had some
temperature when
it was first formed.
But let's imagine I started
at zero Kelvin.
Now, the Stefan-Boltzmann Law
says that an object at zero
temperature does not radiate.
So the Earth would be receiving
heat from the Sun
but not radiating it.
So the amount of heat stored
in the Earth would be
increasing.
That is to say, its temperature
would be
increasing with time, getting
hotter and hotter each day
that went by, receiving more
heat from the Sun, not
radiating it to space.
Well, of course, as soon as it
develops some temperature,
it's going to start
to radiate.
Remember, the Stefan-Boltzmann
Law says the power per unit
area is the sigma times
T to the fourth.
So as soon as T begins to rise,
you get a little bit of
radiation to space.
So this curve will begin to
arc over a little bit, but
eventually, it'll reach a
constant temperature.
And that'll be the case when the
rate of heat received from
the Sun equals the rate
at which energy is
radiating to space.
That's the steady state.
So we made the assumption that
we were in this state.
We equated the incoming
radiation and the outgoing
radiation and found the
temperature that would allow
that balance to be reached.
Remember, if the temperature's
too cold, it won't radiate
enough to keep up with what
the Sun is delivering.
If the temperature is too hot,
it's radiating more than the
Sun is delivering, and the
temperature of the Earth would
cool with time.
But in steady state, that
balance is reached.
And what we did was solve for
that temperature, that single
temperature that would allow
the balance to be reached.
And we derived this nice
little formula, and we
computed some values from it.
So we can summarize that
calculation by looking at this
little list of the things that
control Earth's temperature.
The Sun diameter and the Sun's
temperature, because that
controls how much radiation
is emitted from the Sun.
You can use the Stefan-Boltzmann
Law to figure
out how much each square meter
of the Sun is emitting and
then multiply times the surface
area of the Sun to get
the total amount of Sun's
radiant emission.
It also depends on the Earth-Sun
distance, because as
that radiation moves out away
from the Sun, it diverges, it
spreads out.
And so the local intensity--
that is the watts per
square meter--
decreases.
So if you take a square meter
and put it right at the Sun's
surface, you'll get one value.
You take that same square meter
and move it further way,
it'll have a lesser value,
because some of that radiation
has spread out and is missing
your little one square meter.
So the Earth-Sun distance
is important.
These two things together gave
us the solar constant, the
thing we called capital S, which
you'll recall is about
1,380 watts per square meter.
It depends on the Sun diameter,
the Sun temperature,
and the Earth-Sun distance.
The albedo also came in.
The albedo was the fraction of
the radiation that hits the
Earth that is reflected
back to space.
Now, you know what are
the bright objects
and the dark objects.
Clouds are very bright.
They reflect light
back to space.
Snow fields are very bright.
Bright desert sands and
even bright sand
beaches are very bright.
They have a high albedo.
Forests have a very
low albedo.
Ocean has a very low albedo.
The value we used here-- we
used 33% for the Earth--
that's an average
of all of those.
The bright objects, the dark
objects, sum them all up on
average, for Earth,
it's about 33%.
For other planets,
it's different.
That was important.
And from these considerations,
we came up with that formula
predicting the planet's
temperature, and we found that
it was a little bit low.
And we argued that the reason
it was low is because we had
neglected the greenhouse
effect.
We had assumed that the
long-wave radiation emitted
from the Earth's surface could
just escape to space.
Whereas, in fact, the greenhouse
gases in our
atmosphere, especially water
vapor, CO2, N2O, NO, some
ozone as well, absorbed some
of that outgoing long-wave
radiation in the atmosphere,
heats up the atmosphere, and
some of it gets re-radiated
back to the
surface of the Earth.
That's an extra warming,
if you like.
So our estimates for planetary
temperatures were universally
too cold, because we
had neglected that.
Now, for Earth, it was a pretty
serious discrepancy.
You've got the values in your
notes, but I think it was
something like 30 degrees--
we were 30 degrees too cold in
our simple estimates using
these items. And that makes a
difference between a habitable
planet and an uninhabitable
planet, at least for those
living creatures that depend
on having water
in the liquid form.
So we've learned a lot of
lessons in last time's
lecture, but one of them is
that, well, the greenhouse
effect is our friend.
In other words, it makes
this planet habitable.
Were it not for that, the
temperature would be
universally below the freezing
point for water, and we
wouldn't have the kind of life
that we have. Now, later in
the course when we're talking
about global warming, we'll
come back to this subject and
see maybe the greenhouse
effect is increasing, which
may not be a good thing.
But on a broad-brush analysis,
looking at the habitability of
the planet, the greenhouse
effect is great.
It warms us up to a place
where we can live.
Any questions on that?
So that's in the
way of review.
Now, I want to go on and do
a different subject today.
You may have noticed, or maybe
you haven't, but I'm marching
through these first couple of
weeks of the course some of
the most fundamental ideas
in atmospheric science.
They're not in any
particular order.
I've tried to organize them a
bit so they make sense, but
they're kind of my picks for
the half-dozen or so most
important concepts in
atmospheric science.
And this basic heat budget
thing was one of them.
We did that last time.
Today I want to do another one
called hydrostatic balance.
The basic idea behind
hydrostatic balance is that
air has weight.
Air is heavy.
And the man who first made
this so obvious was the
Frenchman Pascal, who has the
pressure unit named after him.
He took a mercury barometer like
the one that you had in
your lab the other day and
carried that from the base up
to the top of a mountain
in southern France.
Puy-de-Dome is the name
of the mountain.
I've been up there.
I drove up there as a historical
gesture to Pascal.
I wanted to see the place.
And he noted that the pressure
decreases as you go up.
That was a great thing
to notice.
But he also explained it.
He said, listen, the pressure
at each level pushing up has
to support the weight
of the air above it.
And so as you climb up
a mountain, you're
putting some air--
every time you step up, you're
putting some air below you.
So the amount of air above you
decreases the higher you go,
and therefore the pressure
will decrease as well.
Because the less air you have
above you, the less weight you
have to support with that
pressure pushing up.
This was remarkable.
It seems so simple today,
but yet it really did
revolutionize the way
we thought about the
atmosphere and so on.
So here's the idea.
We're going to repeat his
calculation, hydrostatic
balance.
"Static" here meaning there's
no acceleration--
it's just a static balance--
"hydro" referring to fluid.
Now, we're talking about
air, but this applies
to liquids as well.
So here is a column of air
extending from sea level up
until we're outside
the atmosphere.
So of course, the atmosphere
doesn't have a definite top,
but we'll go up 10, 20 scale
heights, and so we're above
virtually all the atmosphere.
So there's no pressure pushing
down at the top of this,
because there's no
air up there.
But there is a pressure
pushing up.
It's the ground pushing up on
the air or the air pushing
down on the ground,
either one.
They have to be in balance.
The pressure force pushing up on
this column of fluid is the
value of the pressure
times the base
area of that cylinder.
Think of it as a cylinder
going up to space.
So P times A has
units of force.
So remember, pressure is
a force per unit area.
So when I multiply it times an
area, I'll get something with
units of force-- that is to say,
Newtons in the SI system.
Now, this air column has a
certain amount of mass, and
I'll call that capital M. And
any time you've got mass and
you put it in the gravitational
field of a
planet, that object
will have weight.
And you compute the weight by
multiplying the mass times the
acceleration of gravity.
So now, here's where the word
"balance" comes in.
I'm going to equate
those two things.
I'm going to say that this is a
static system, so the weight
of that air is held up by the
pressure force pushing up at
the bottom of the column.
So there I've done it.
The pressure times the area--
that's the vector up--
is equal to M times g--
that's the weight
vector pulling down.
I've just rearranged that.
I've divided through by A and
divided through by g to get M
over A. That's the mass per
unit area is equal to the
surface pressure divided by the
acceleration of gravity.
This is the fundamental form
in which we use it.
This has units of kilograms
per square meter.
And now leave an inch
in your notes and
work out these units.
This should have the
same units as that.
This one is obvious, kilograms
per square meter.
This one's not so obvious.
You're going to have to remember
what the units for
pressure are and for g and work
that out to see if the
units check on that.
So that's the basic assumption,
and that's the
basic equation that
results from it.
The mass per unit area in a
column reaching from sea level
to outside the atmosphere is
just given by the pressure at
sea level divided by the
acceleration of gravity.
Now, we could do a quick
calculation of this.
For surface pressure, I would
put in about 1,000--
let's see--
101,300 Pascals, and I would
divide that by 9.81.
Let's round that off to 10.
So I'll just knock a decimal
place off here, and that'll be
one 3 with one 0.
That's going to be kilograms
per square meter.
And that's about 10
metric tons, 10
tons per square meter.
In other words, if you walk
outside and imagine this
one-square-meter base area and
that column going up, there's
about 10 tons of air
in that column.
Any questions on that?
A pretty simple calculation.
And it works.
It's very accurate, actually.
Now, that's a big step, and
it was pretty easy.
I've got another big step
that's awful easy too.
Now that I know the amount of
mass per unit area, I can
quickly compute the total amount
of mass in the Earth's
atmosphere.
I just have to know the
area of a sphere.
We used that the other day
for another purpose.
That's 4 pi r squared.
So if each square meter of
Earth's surface has this much
mass standing above it, then I
just multiply that by 4 pi r
squared, which is the total
number of square meters on the
surface of the Earth, and I
get the atmospheric mass.
So the atmospheric mass is given
by P over g, which is
the same as M over A, times
4 pi r squared.
Now, this r is the radius
of the planet.
So I've done the calculation
here again.
I've put in 1,013, 9.81,
like I did there.
4 pi.
There is the radius
of the planet.
Now remember, I had to
get that in meters.
Everything has to be in
consistent units.
You square that out, and you
get 54 times 10 to the 17
kilograms. So just like that, we
got the mass of the Earth's
atmosphere.
Questions on that?
I'm going to extend that
calculation a little bit
further now.
If we've measured with some
device the mixing ratio of CO2
in the atmosphere--
how much CO2 is mixed in--
we measure it locally and assume
that the ratio of CO2
to air is the same everywhere.
It's not a bad approximation.
CO2 is pretty well mixed
in the atmosphere.
It varies by a few percent, but
not much more than that,
around the whole Earth's
atmosphere.
Then I could compute
the amount of
mass of CO2, basically.
Remember, though, there's a
couple of ways to represent
mixing ratio.
For example, you might see the
mixing ratio of CO2 in square
brackets sometimes written at
about 390 parts per million by
volume (390ppmv).
That's a molecular count.
That's how many molecules of
CO2 per molecule of air.
Or you can forget the pp--
that's parts per million--
and write it 390 times 10 to
the minus six by volume.
But you might want it by mass
instead, in which case you'd
have to multiply up front
by the ratio of
the molecular weights.
CO2 is 44.
Air is 29.
You put the same number
in there, you get 550.
That's the concentration of
carbon dioxide by mass, parts
per million by mass (ppmm).
It ends with an m
instead of a v.
Well then, if you want to know
the amount of carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere, you've got
the total amount here, just
multiply that number
times that number.
Don't forget, there's a 10 the
minus six in this parts per
million thing here.
That's 10 to the minus six.
And bingo, you've got the amount
of CO2 in the Earth's
atmosphere.
So from a few simple ideas, our
quantitative understanding
of the atmosphere is advancing
by leaps and bounds with these
simple calculations.
Yes.
STUDENT: I'm sorry.
What was the 29, again?
PROFESSOR: The 29 is the
molecular weight of air.
You'll recall that the molecular
weight of nitrogen
is 28, and the molecular
weight of oxygen is 32.
There's more nitrogen than
oxygen, so the average is a
little closer to
28 than to 32.
It comes out to be almost
exactly 29 for the average
molecular weight of air, being
a mixture of N2 and O2.
That's how that number
comes from.
Good question.
Other questions or comments?
Now, there's another form of
the hydrostatic relation.
This is for the total column.
There's another form which
involves just looking at a
little segment of
the atmosphere.
So imagine a little cylinder.
You might want to still consider
it a cylinder,
perhaps, but you slice it here,
and you slice it there,
and you just consider this
little stub of an atmosphere.
And you want to know how the
pressure is different at the
bottom than the top.
And while I do this derivation,
I have a volunteer
who is going to take the Kestrel
that you're familiar
with and run up to the top of
KBT and measure the pressure
at the ground floor
and the top floor.
And when she comes back in
class, we will have finished a
prediction of what she will
measure for that pressure
difference, based on
the derivation
I'm about to do here.
Thanks very much.
Now, in many ways-- in some
ways, the calculation is
similar to this one.
But instead of looking at the
whole atmospheric column,
we're just going to consider
this little stub of a column.
So there's a pressure at the
bottom, which I'll call P sub
B. That's the pressure
at the bottom
of that little cylinder.
The pressure at the top is P sub
T. The horizontal area of
that little chunk is capital
A. Its height is delta z.
In other words, that's the
difference between the
altitude at the bottom and
the altitude at the top.
I usually use z in this
course for altitude.
STUDENT: What is A?
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
PROFESSOR: A is the
top area of the cylinder.
So now there are three forces
acting on this thing.
There's a pressure at the
bottom acting on area A
pushing up, and that's
the little vector
I've drawn in there.
There's a pressure at the top
acting over the same area A,
so it's P Top times A. That's
the vector pointing down.
And there's another down vector,
and that's the weight
of the mass in that chunk.
And if you want to know the mass
of a fluid, you multiply
the density, if you have
it, times the volume.
So I've written it here as Greek
letter rho for density,
and then the volume is the
product of the area and the
height of the cylinder.
Do you remember that
from trigonometry?
The volume of the cylinder
is just the area times
the height of it.
So that's the volume.
So those three things together--
rho, A, delta z--
that's the mass of the air.
It has units of kilograms,
like the M over here.
And then I multiply it times
g to get the weight.
Now, I want to simplify that
formula a little bit.
Notice A appears in each of the
three terms. So I cancel
that out, I bring the PT over,
and I keep the rho g delta z
on the right-hand side.
And this is the formula that
I've then derived for the
hydrostatic law extending over
some small range of altitudes.
It says that the pressure at the
bottom is greater than the
pressure at the top by an amount
given by the product of
the air density, the
acceleration of gravity, and
the height of the object, the
height of the air chunk, the
air parcel.
Questions on that?
Let's do a calculation then.
She's gone up to Kline
Biology Tower.
She'll take a measurement here,
take the elevator up to
the 12th floor, take a
measurement there, and then
come back to class.
So we've got to hurry up
and get a prediction
of what that is.
So we're interested in the
difference between P at the
bottom and P at the top.
So here's what we need to do.
We're going to use the standard
value for air density
at sea level.
It varies a little bit, but
for most purposes we can
assume that it's 1.2 kilograms
per cubic meter.
g is 9.81.
Units on that are meters
per second squared.
And we have to get the
height, the delta z.
Now, this is 12 floors, and
I'm assuming that there's
about four meters from
floor to floor.
For example, here, I think
that's about nine or 10 feet,
which is about three meters.
But then there's a certain
thickness before you get up to
the next floor.
So this is a pretty
crude estimate.
I've never measured it, but
I'm going to assume that
there's four meters per floor,
so that's 48 meters for the
height of Kline Biology Tower.
We could measure this, and I
probably would find that I
have some error here.
But to a rough approximation,
that's going to be 48 meters.
Now, check the units on this,
because when I multiply these
things together, I've
got to get something
with units of Pascals.
And let me see what I come
up with when I do that
calculation.
Yes, this gives me 565.
If anyone has a calculator,
please check me on this,
because I'm not sure I can read
my own handwriting here.
565 Pascals.
Would someone check me on
that, please, with a
calculator?
1.2 times 9.81 times 48.
Is that about right?
It's 565?
OK.
Now, the instrument she's
reading, the Kestrel reads out
in hectoPascals, which is
a hundredth of a Pascal.
So we are predicting that
she will find a pressure
difference of 5.65 hectoPascals,
which is also
millibars, by the way.
And so we'll see when
she comes back.
Now, this is a pretty useful
idea, and you've used it
already in your lab.
For example, when you were
using the-- a question.
Yes.
STUDENT: Sorry.
Is a hectoPascal 100 Pascals or
one hundredth of a Pascal?
PROFESSOR: A hectoPascal is
100 Pascals, yes.
So 565 Pascal is 5.65
hectoPascals.
I get that switched
all the time.
We've used the hydrostatic law
in your lab a couple of times.
For example, when you're using
the mercury barometer, you are
assuming that hydrostatic
balance held within the
mercury fluid.
The atmospheric pressure
was pushing down on
the top of the reservoir.
There's a vacuum above, so
there's nothing pushing down
on the mercury.
But the weight of that mercury
column is balanced by
atmospheric pressure pushing
on the reservoir.
Let me just sketch that out.
I know you did this in class
also, but the mercury lies in
here and up to there.
So atmospheric pressure acting
down here supports that column
of mercury.
And this calculation would
work perfectly for that.
Just remember, there's a vacuum
up here, so there's no
pressure pushing down, but the
pressure pushing up is exactly
balancing the weight of the
column of mercury standing
above the base level.
I believe you also used it when
you were correcting your
pressure measurement to
go down to sea level.
You measured the pressure here
in the laboratory, but that's
a few meters above sea level,
and so you needed to compute a
correction to add to that to get
the pressure at sea level.
Are there any questions about
the hydrostatic law before I
change gears?
I'm waiting for her to come
back, but I've got a few more
things I want to
say about this.
But I'd prefer to take
your questions now.
Here we go.
Could you just call out the
pressures for this?
STUDENT: For the ground
level, it was 1,007.9.
PROFESSOR: 1,007.9.
STUDENT: And then the 12th
floor was 1,002.2.
PROFESSOR: 1,002.2.
So that difference is 5.7.
Wow.
Did we do good?
Look at that.
5.65, 5.7.
We did good on that.
It doesn't usually come out
that well, actually.
Congratulations.
You're good.
You jiggied those numbers
just right, so we
got the right answer.
You get the point.
Now, you didn't scale up the
outside of the building.
You went in and took the
elevator up, I presume, right?
STUDENT: Yes.
PROFESSOR: So the
question is how was she able
to get good numbers like this
inside the building?
Isn't the inside of the building
different than
outside, where things are free
to the rest of the atmosphere?
Not really, because buildings
leak around the windows and
everywhere.
So when you walk into a
building, the pressure changes
very, very little.
The outside pressure, inside
pressure is about the same,
with a couple of exceptions.
If you play tennis at one of
these inflatable tennis
courts-- you know what I'm
talking about, they blow these
things up?--
you walk into that building,
you have to
kind of pull the door--
high pressure inside, so
you kind of have to
push to get in there.
If you feel when you're entering
that building a
pressure resistance when you
go through the doors--
and most buildings
don't have that--
but if you feel it, there's
some kind of active air
conditioning that's keeping the
pressure inside higher or
lower than outside.
And you might want to worry
then about whether your
measurements are the same
inside and outside.
But for the most part, you can
measure the pressure inside a
building, and it's the same
as it is outside.
So in the laboratory, when I had
you measure the pressure
using the mercury barometer in
Room 120, that's the same as
the atmospheric pressure
outside.
There's no pressure differential
in that building.
You couldn't do that
with temperature.
Temperature's different inside,
humidity's different
inside, but the pressure
likes to equalize.
And so this is a very robust
calculation, as the agreement
shows there.
Other questions about
hydrostatic?
Let's spend a few
minutes on this.
Questions on hydrostatic law?
Yeah.
STUDENT: Where do
you get the 1.2?
PROFESSOR: That is a standard
value, sea-level density.
You can compute it from the
perfect gas law if you know
the pressure and the
temperature.
I think we did that.
If you measure the temperature
in this room and the pressure
in this room, you can use
the perfect gas law
to solve for that.
And I think we did
that earlier.
Now, as you go up in the
atmosphere, of course, that
value changes.
By the way, this simple formula
has a value for
density in it.
That means you couldn't use it
to predict pressure difference
over a very great height
difference, because the
density changes over a great
height difference.
And so you wouldn't know what
value to put in for rho.
So this formula is best used
over distances of a couple of
hundred meters or less.
If you're going to compute
pressure difference over a
much greater distance, I would
use that exponential formula
that we had in class
a week ago.
So this is for short distances
delta z, because it's assumed
a constant value for density.
Now, by the way, this same law
operates in the oceans.
As you go down in the oceans,
the pressure increases at a
rate given quite precisely
by the hydrostatic law.
It's accurate to within at
least one part in 1,000,
probably one part in 10,000,
so a very accurate
calculation.
And for that, it's a bit easier,
because the density of
water doesn't change very much
as you go down in the ocean.
Water is nearly an
incompressible liquid.
It doesn't change its volume
when you put it
under a high pressure.
But remember, the density for
water is much, much greater
than that for air.
What is the density of water?
Anybody know?
I bet you know from
your problem set.
One--
STUDENT: 1,000 kilograms--
PROFESSOR: 1,000
kilograms per cubic meter,
about 1,000 times that value.
So water is about 1,000
times denser than air.
So I've been trying to impress
on you today that air has
mass, but of course, water
has much more mass.
Water is much denser
liquid than air is.
Other comments or questions
about the hydrostatic law?
Yes.
STUDENT: I understand the
practical applications of this
for the ocean, but what are
some ways this is used in
meteorology?
PROFESSOR: Let me
give you an example of that.
Notice that the rate at which
the pressure increases as you
go down depends on the
density of the air.
So let's say in the center
of a hurricane, you had
a lot of warm air.
If you look at the perfect gas
law, you can find that warm
air at the same pressure
is less dense.
So you have a value of rho here
that is relatively small
compared to the rho out
here, which is larger.
Small rho in the center of the
hurricane, large rho outside
the hurricane.
Now, let's say you've got the
same pressure everywhere here,
but as you come down in the
atmosphere here, through the
low-density region, pressure
increases.
But it increases slowly,
because rho is smaller.
Here, pressure increases, but
it increases more rapidly,
because rho is larger.
Remember, the story here in this
box is that the pressure
increases as you go down at a
rate given by the air density.
So if the pressure is the same
at all locations up here, by
the time I work my way down
under here, I'm going to have
low pressure and relatively
higher
pressure outside the hurricane.
So this hydrostatic law is the
reason why there is low
pressure in the center
of a hurricane.
We'll talk about this later
on in the course.
We'll talk about hurricanes.
But we see it now, this basic
law is responsible for this
very important property of
hurricanes having low pressure
in the center.
Because there's warm air aloft,
and the warm air is
less dense, has a smaller
value of density.
Then just use that formula, and
you'll get that very nice
and very practical, very
important result.
In fact, we typically-- very
often, we measure the strength
of a hurricane by how low that
pressure reaches in the center
of the hurricane.
What you're really measuring
when you do that is the amount
of warm air aloft.
And that's a good thing, because
that's an important
aspect of the structure
of a hurricane.
So there's a good example
for that question.
Other issues, other questions?
Let's quit a bit early today.
I'll see you on Friday.